hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar candida rs pcr screening for
infection prevention
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by diasoren molecular to learn more
visit molecular.diocerin.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
all questions will be answered following
the broadcast via email
you may also submit any technical
technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr maura pioretti scientific director
for bay care laboratories
maura you may now begin your
presentation
thank you thank you very much to lab
ruth and dice soaring for giving me the
opportunity to share my lab's experience
in dealing with candida oras i also want
to point out that i'm not um receiving
any compensation for this seminar and
therefore i have no conflicts of
interest to declare at all
um
so
we will start by
describing the impact of this relatively
newly identified east
and why this topic is so relevant and so
serious
we will review identification challenges
review recommendations for screening
algorithms
we will
also go over how we implemented these
algorithms
we will go over how we implemented our
laboratory test
implementation and validation and review
the data that we have accumulated so far
i'd like to start by reviewing
a few facts about candida ores
um let's start by saying that it first
of all was identified in 2009 so it's
not too long ago and it was identified
in japan initially from a ear canal
infection
um the name or is actually derives from
the latin word auris which means ear
and candida or is quickly spread and was
rapidly identified throughout the world
in 2011 in fact the first blood stream
infection was identified in korea
um candida always tend to infect
patients who are already ill or have
other serious medical conditions and
such as people who have long stays in
hospitals or in in nursing homes
the mortality unfortunately that is
associated with candida or as infection
is very high in fact about one-third of
patients
will end up dying
and that's very unfortunate
the other
component of candida or is apart from
infection it also it tends to colonize
patients it has the ability to persist
on the environment colonize patients and
patients who have no symptoms
and have are not affected by an
infection
so these colonized patients can spread
it to um to other patients and therefore
candida or is it is a true health
acquired infection and it's becoming a
really serious one
to ask for the gravity uh of this
pathogen it is also very resistant to
treatment and some strains are resistant
to all three classes of anti-fungal
medications azoles aquino candidates and
amphotericin b
and then the last leg of this threat
is also the fact that this this organism
is not being very easy to identify in
the laboratory unless very specialized
testing and technologies were used and
of course
misidentification or wrong
identification can equally
lead to an appropriate therapy and and
also to further spread
you can see with all of these really
great matters why the cdc
uh really classified this threat as
urgent and in fact
the cdc uh in 2006
sounded the alarm
for this threat being classified as
urgent
only about one week later
the public health in england announced
that it had identified um candida oris
in uh the whole followed very soon after
warning about candida oris and then the
european cdc commission also sounded the
alarm over this
reports in the press of course
add on to making this visible to the
public eye as it should in cases began
spreading in the u.s starting in 2015
more and more clinical cases of
infections were identified with a
dramatic increase every year
this chart here which is from the cdc uh
shows the 300 over three hundred percent
increase that occur between uh 2015 and
2018.
moving on to the spread uh this global
map here um shows how
the spread is really worrisome
this is again from the cdc website
and it shows how many countries over 30
countries in the world including the us
have identified cases of infection and
local spread
other facts around this is that of
course the cost to the health care
system is particularly high this is the
cost that has been estimated with for
candida or is infections in u.s hospital
over a million dollar
blood stream infection are uh very um
very important and very grave and they
are those that tend to be have the
higher mortality associated with them
when i looked at actually the cdc
website again just recently um this um
show is showing again uh the the
map of the world where candida or has
been identified but specifically
this sentence here made me really pause
this map is no longer being updated
given how widespread
candida auris has become and this was as
of february 2021 so it gives you a
little bit about
the how worrisome the situation is
what is also uh interesting is the fact
that it appears that different
candida artists with different clonality
have probably emerged in the world
independently of each other and this is
at least according to data from whole
genome sequencing
isolated from different parts of the
world that actually belong to different
clades and as you can see here on this
uh phytogenetic tree you see first of
all how closely related candida oris is
to other types of candida such as for
example candida himuloni you can also
see the five different clades that we
now know as of today and we know also
that clade one two and um
and four are responsible for
invasive
invasive outbreaks by multi-drug
resistance strains
[Music]
plate 2 is being is the one that was
first isolated in east asia
clay five is the most recent one uh with
cases isolated in in iran according to
reports so uh it is interesting that um
they've probably evolved um
simultaneously and independently of each
other
the observation that different clonal
lineages are distributed over the united
states for example is really supporting
the idea that these have been
independent introduction with subsequent
local spread inside the u.s
moving on to other characteristics of
candida or is it is a very hardy
pathogen
um it and it is quite different from
other candidas it can grow in the
presence of
high salt
over 10 sodium chloride
um which is again different from other
candidas um
it is also uh interesting that two
studies have reported that in the
presence of high salt it actually can
form uh some pseudo-hyphy
like morphologies and this suggests that
this transition may be an ad an adaptive
um modification that this organism is
capable of doing when uh conditions
change
um can live uh at high temperature
relatively high temperatures compared to
other candidates in fact it it lives
very well at human physiological
temperatures between 36.5 and 37.5
degrees centigrade and it can live up to
40 degrees and even 42 degrees which
would be really high fever
it is very resilient
it can survive
on both biotic surfaces but also abiotic
surfaces and in fact
viable candida oris that can be
grown in the lab has been recovered from
bed rails door knobs
etc where it actually creates a sort of
a biofilm
um and so this obviously
you you can imagine how this can
definitely contribute to the uh spread
within the healthcare setting settings
so the transmission
that has been demonstrated is definitely
from human to human through contact but
also through environmental surfaces and
this
occurs as you can imagine a very can
occur in hospitals especially when the
long term there's a long-term care stay
or in nursing homes
so the associated risk for infections
are the length of stay in um in specific
units within the hospital other diseases
an immunosuppressed state
and um
exposure to antibiotics and
age and devices which we'll see
a little bit more in detail
let's let's now look at uh
for a few minutes to uh at the clinical
presentation of the invisible section
again i'm a laboratory and i'm not a
clinician but i wanted to um do a little
bit of an overview on the actual
clinical presentation
as mentioned uh the infection uh very
often occurs in people who are already
ill which can make recognizing the
symptoms really really difficult
it occurs in patients who have breathing
tubes feeding tubes central venous
catheters
patients
who have previously received antibiotics
or antifungal medications
the early symptoms can be fever
respiratory distress and the lack of
response to antibiotics
but it may depend also may vary very
much with the site the primary side of
infection
candidemia if it occurs which is
basically the infection in the blood
will
lead to blood dissemination and it can
end up producing a generalized infection
septic shock
and multi-organ failure
it is therefore cdc recommends
preventing this type of infection
especially in people who have devices
such as feeding tools breathing tubes
and catheters um really the adequate
management of these devices is really
important to uh
to try and limit um the
the infection itself
so colonization on the other hand
makes people mostly asymptomatic but
capable of transmissions to others
and importantly they are also at risk of
developing their own invasive infections
so especially if they're already ill
so while colonization clinically is less
important however from a healthcare
perspective is particularly important to
identify colonized patients
so they need to be screened in order to
be identified
more recently more recent data just
to really point out clinical cases and
colonization cases and again this is
from the cdc
um you can see how in the past year this
is 12 months worth of data from
september 2020 to august 2021 there have
been over a thousand clinical cases
reported and over 3 000 colonization
cases reported
also note the distribution of cases on
the u.s map
which is not equal so some states much
more affected than other states
states in the northeast california texas
and florida
as well as illinois appear to be the
case this states with the most cases to
date
to add to this really really dire
situation uh with candida oris uh of
course we also had uh the kobe 19
pandemic and in here really um
candida ores
became a lurking threat
for a lot of kobe patients
covetations who tend to have long
hospital faith
and are already by themselves
severely ill um
where basically we had
co-infections so candida oris and covet
uh 19 stars kov2
reported and a few outbreaks in several
states in the u.s
including the one that i'm reporting
right here in florida that was published
in mmwr
in january 2021
so really
a
perfect combination of really um
high risk situations for these patients
or staying in the hospital
i'd like to move on now to
lab identification
and all the challenges relating to a lab
identification
as i mentioned uh this is this is the
organism has not been easy to identify
and has been often
misidentified or missed altogether
there are
four categories that i'm going to be
going over regarding
lab identification phenotypic
biochemical and molded off and molecular
identification
the challenges have been that because
candida is so closely related to other
types of candidas it has been
misidentified as those
and also the other challenge is that it
is not common practice in the laboratory
to speciate all candidas unless they are
identified in infections from uh sterol
sites so there um there are about 40
percent of clinical cases are not from
the blood are for example urine and bile
and in general laboratories have not uh
been in the practice of speciating
candidas
uh to the species level when it comes
from non-sterol isolates
so they would be basically just being
reported as uh as candida at the genus
level only obviously in a healthcare
setting that has candida or a spread
this will need to change
and it's recommended
by the by the cdc
genotypic identification what we mean by
that is is basically looking at colonies
on a plate
on growth plates and there have been
many challenges uh because it's very
hard uh to identify and very easy to
misidentify
uh what i'm showing here i'm actually
are actually some specialized agriplates
the chrome overplays which are not
the the plates uh that are commonly used
in most laboratories it they can help
somehow in the identification but even
with these plates the colonies are
really hard to tell apart from other
types of candida as you can see here in
the left picture candida glabrata is
purple tropicalis is blue and oris is
white however not very easy to
distinguish and then um
also because in some cases as you can
see a pure pure pure colonies here of
candida or is on the middle plate and
even in those cases the the color
morphology can vary from white to purple
so
bottom line is that phenotypic
identification can absolutely not be the
sole method of identification for this
organism
the biochemical methods are also a
little bit fraught with errors um
we i'm listing here in this table
various types of commercial systems that
are used in a lot of clinical
laboratories at least in the u.s
and
all of them pretty much
have had trouble identifying candida or
as as you can see candida himuloni could
be
id'd and in fact when candida ores was
actually present uh and and other types
of candida this is changing uh
fortunately uh recently however this has
probably led to a lot of
misidentification just in the past
and
probably still is if these systems have
not been updated
fortunately
matrix assisted laser absorption
ionization time of flight more commonly
referred to as moldy
moldy tough mass spectrometer has really
come to health
um
these these systems and i'm showing here
uh the two major systems that are
available at least in u.s clinical lab
the broker and the vo mario are now
both capable of correctly identifying
coris
however the it all depends on the
database and the library that is uh
loaded on these instruments if the
software has to be the ibd claim for and
more recent for the broker and it has to
be the ibd library version 3.2 or more
reason for the vmware you prior versions
of the software was actually not
identifying candida oris
so good news for those who have
mass spec in their clinical micro labs
but again the right software and the
right library need to be added here
and then it comes to molecular methods
and of course molecular methods identify
of course the genetic material
in the case of candida oris ribosomal
dna seems to be the preferred target for
both sequencing and amplification-based
methods
and this is reported in a variety of
publications
for sequencing the d1 and d2 region of
the 28s ribosomal dna or the internal
transcribed region ips so the also the
ribosomal dna can accurately identify
candida ores and the reason are
a few um it is a very good region to
target here because it is a universally
represented in fungi it has multi-copy
nature so it's easier to pick up
so there's this really well conserved
regions but they're also interspaced
with highly variable regions that allow
for differentiation of closely related
species as you can see in the graph here
at the bottom of the slide
um so obviously this is a very good way
to conclusively identify candida or is
of course uh our dna sequencing is not
available in all labs amplification
methods
on the other hand are a little bit more
available they target the same regions
and also they can bring to the same a
precise identification of candida auris
um i also want to mention here um the
gen mark e plex block culture id fungal
panel
which to my knowledge is the only one
test that is actually an fda approved
molecular test uh in the u.s for the
identification of candida ores however
obviously this is just for positive
blood cultures that's
where how the panel is is meant to be
used um
so i wanted to mention that as well as
an extra tool
when it comes to molecular methods in
general um
they all rely on amplification as i said
of the genetic material they come in
many flavors of course there are many
different types of molecular
amplification methods
uh different types of pcr or other type
of isothermal amplification and of
course
the big winner seems always to be
real-time pcr in terms of how frequently
this is being used in the literature and
how frequently this is implemented in
laboratories
um a few consideration is
my lab was thinking of
adopting an amplification method for the
identification of c or it is of course
what what are the important
characteristics that we're choosing that
we are wanting in this method so
obviously we want the method to be
sensitive specific uh of course that
will depend on the primer sequences and
the probe location
um
what other equipment is already
available in the laboratory so that we
don't
you know obviously need to purchase
something specific just for one new test
what type of clinical samples do we need
this a molecular method for is it for
the identification of positive colonies
or for the identification of
colonization so very different clinical
scenarios
of course also cost is always a big
issue in laboratories these days and um
how much cost is lab really willing to
absorb as you know if you added a new
identification method not necessarily
you get more reimbursement all the time
so uh what what can lab absorb in terms
of cost of setting up new things that
help in uh the diagnosis of disease or
the uh on screening methodology uh but
um
what can really be done uh and also of
course it's uh the turnaround time that
is needed is very important choosing the
methodology
and also as you can all imagine what
else is going on in the laboratory
as
my specific experience we were in the
process of considering implementation of
c ors molecular methodology
as we will see later and we started
thinking about this at the end of 2019
actually probably earlier than that but
started making the final plans for
actually going live at the beginning of
2020 with this new test
until of course covet happened and we
had to put everything on hold and deal
with the urgent threat
at the time
as a conclusion to the review of the
laboratory methods here before i move on
to my own experience with implementing
this i also i mentioned the fact a
couple of times that
candida ore seems to be very resistant
so i wanted to take a minute to look at
a susceptibility and first of all
remind that the clsi guidelines
recommend to co to do complete
susceptibility studies for candida auris
that are isolated from an infection
um i however also want to remind you
that there are no established breakup
breakpoints to date and there's no
correlation uh final correlation between
the breakpoints and the clinical
outcomes
um so this is obviously working that
data that will be changing i'm hoping
that clsi will update very soon
but this is the situation at the moment
um and these are the three classes here
of antifungal medication that are
commonly used and you can see that
unfortunately the main drought
fluconazole and this is the azole
category um candida or is is over 90 of
candida aureus is resistant to
fluconazole so obviously this is not a
drug of choice uh 30 percent of the
isolates are also going to be as um
resistant to um footperiton
and um so
with the last class of anti-fungal
medications still showing uh the least
amount of resistance so probably being
the drug choice in the majority of cases
here
okay so now i want to move on to my
specific experience my labs experience
with the um
candida oris and um candida oris
was spreading in florida
as early as 2017.
it was first isolated in the south part
of southern parts of the uh the state
uh with the first few cases in 2017 in
the miami-dade counties uh mostly with
local transmission within and between
healthcare systems
more recently however with that cases
also in other areas of of the northern
and western parts of florida and as you
can see the symbol here daycare my
healthcare system is located on the west
coast of florida
so a couple more words specifically
regarding the daycare healthcare system
for which i work
and i'm showing you a sort of a blow up
for the tampa bay region um and um
you can see that the the tampa bay
region is located on the west coast of
florida
we our healthcare system covers a pretty
large area
um tampa bay region is home to almost
four million people and daycare
healthcare represents 40 almost 40
percent of the healthcare for this
population here what i'm showing here is
all of our different hospital labs so
that each microscope here represents a
lab in the area and our hospital labs
are pretty sophisticated uh we have a
lot of decentralized testing when it
comes to molecular testing a lot of pcr
testing a lot of covet testing is
actually done at the hospital labs
closed locations
we also have however a central core lab
which is indicated by the
star here the red star in the map and
the central lab has a core microbiology
laboratory a core molecular laboratory
and other areas
of specialized testing such as
cytogenetics or cytometry and so forth
so we uh
came into um i also want to mention here
uh before i forget that the
core microbiology laboratory is
fortunate enough to actually have all
three systems that can now
accurately identify candida or is
from positive
cultures from in from infections we have
both mass spec
um instruments as well as the um vitae 2
software uh version 8.01
which allows for the specific
identification of c oris it is true that
with this system just as a word of
caution if other candida such as
hemiloni for example are identified it
is still possible that a candida auras
may be present so more studies or more
identification with the mass spec may be
needed but it can identify cors at this
point
so
we
as i mentioned we started seeing candida
orange cases in florida and we actually
reported and recorded the first case of
infection within our health care system
exactly in march 2020
which of course all remember as at the
beginning of testing for a lot of our
laboratories for uh source covey tomb
this patient had been transferred from a
long-term acute care facility
and um
we
identified it and
immediately started a screening protocol
for identifying colonization
so we
recognized the threat unfortunately the
lab at that point was not able to uh to
do any testing in-house
however
screening for colonization and
identifying colonization of patients who
have been exposed to infected is
particularly important so i want to go
back for a second to talk about
colonization so
colonization uh is occurs in those
people who uh
um
have theories but
are not infected are asymptomatic
unfortunately these patients can remind
remain colonized for months
and uh these patients can spread it to
others but are also a risk to themselves
also importantly my infection prevention
uh colleagues tell me that there is
really no good way at the moment to
decolonize patients
and so that's really despite trying with
baths with chlorohexidine and other
agents it's really important
almost impossible to decolonize them
completely
so where do people get colonized they
can colonize in the mouth the rectum the
urine the nose uh the the ear the
external ear canal however it seems from
uh consensus in the literature the that
the best spots in the body uh that where
people are um
always colonize and seem to be the best
spot for collections are the axilla and
the groin and so these are the uh the
sites that are actually being uh
collected when somebody is tested for
colonization
and whom to screen there are a lot of
publications around this and a lot of
recommendations and of course whoever
comes in contact with an infected
patient
and
also the recommendations are to screen
patients who are admitted to the
hospitals who have a history of a health
care space abroad
patients who
are colonized or infected for
carbopenem-producing organisms
and
patients who have a suspected exposure
so based on these recommendations we
started our own
screening algorithm and infection
prevention here at daycare was
kind enough to share their algorithm
with us as we've been very close
collaborators in this as many as other
projects so candida oris of course is
subject to contact bleach precaution if
somebody is infected and so there are
many signs and many things that need to
be taken into consideration when
treating these patients um
we put in charge the infection
prevention team to identify patients
and gave them some tools such as what we
call them a standard order for patients
with a history previous histories of
sierras as i said before
patients with history of carbopen and
resistant organisms roommates and so
forth and so infection prevention has
been in charge of screening patients who
are at risk of being colonized and we
have
developed very
precise guidelines on what to use we're
using nylon flux swaps those that come
in a white cap with liquid any seems to
be what is also being used in the
literature from what i've seen and we're
instructing everybody to collect both
the right and left axilla and then with
the same swab collect the right and left
groin
and um
and then bring these to the lab as i
mentioned previously we were not able to
do these in the lab immediately and so
we started by actually sending our
screening tests um based on this
algorithm to the closest lab the
part of the network and the closest
for us was the tennessee state lab
which was great in that they were
setting up cultures and pcrs
for us and uh however due to the
distance in transportation the paperwork
work involved
obviously this
the results were not back in a really
really timely fashion
to really quickly identify colonized
patients
so um
we decided that we needed to move on and
and start looking at molecular methods
inside
inside our own central core laboratory
so we ended up developing a laboratory
develop test and
we had already quite a bit of experience
with asrs specifically asrs from
dinosaurin as well as other vendors and
we looked at our options and we decided
that this
was a was a good uh combination of
reagents available the um
primer pair uh in the asr from diosurin
targets the its2 region is labeled with
fam
we
also knew that we needed other
components which we were already very
familiar with such as extraction and
amplification reagents containing
internal control dna and primers to
control for pcr inhibition
we also knew that
we had an experience with a temperature
activated master mix which allows for
direct essay that do not require a
separate extraction
eventually and i'll talk about this a
little in in a minute um we ended up
also um investigating this fungal lysis
solution from diasporin which ended up
being very helpful and we knew that
there were several control materials
available from variety of vendors as
well as cdc
so we set up to um to set up our own
essay and actually we tried quite a few
things because we really wanted this
essay to be
relatively quick fast relatively simple
to set up
especially since we uh we were really
busy with uh doing uh thousands and
thousands of kobe tests so we tried
first the direct sample approach with no
instruction at all and putting the
sample directly into the pcr master mix
and this obviously was very fast but it
was really not quite as sensitive as we
wanted it to be
we tried a few a couple of few um
off-board extractions and um of course
this is not a very extensive list we
decided that this is was also not really
adding a whole lot to the sensitivity
and the sample just didn't seem to lie
sufficiently with the methods we tried
but we could have tried a few more
things of course but then the fungal
lysis buffer came available available
from uh dinosaur and so we tried this
and it actually proved to be uh the
winning ticket um
the fungal lysis buffer allows us to
basically lines the sample ahead of time
by adding uh some uh volume of the
sample with
about one tenth of the volume with um of
lysis buffer uh the
sample pretty much cooks uh for 16
minutes it's 30 minutes at 60 degrees
centigrade where it lies quite
efficiently is then in deactivated at 95
degrees centigrade for 10 minutes and
then it's basically ready to be set up
in amplification uh where uh we're using
uh for
many different real-time pcr instruments
could be using used here uh we're using
the diastoring lysosome mdx and the 96
well
direct
sample
plate
using two microliters of samples and
eight microliters of master mix
so
as again as i said we we tried it a few
things but this seemed to be working
pretty well and i'm showing you uh here
some just some examples of results where
you can see the amplification curves i
have four samples here to our patients
and to our controls and you can see that
the amplification curves uh of the first
patient is just purple that's just the
internal control the amplification curve
of the second patient is actually both
the green and the purple curve
indicating amplification of
uh the target for sea auris as well and
these are the negative and the positive
control
um
so after we uh we finish with sort of
this um
finding out what the best conditions
were or we could do our validation
studies to be able to bring this test uh
live in-house uh as i'm sure a lot of
the laboratories here in the audience
are familiar validation studies of
course include accuracy precision
sensitivity and specificity for accuracy
um
i must say was relatively easy for us
because we were already sending the test
out we were already swabbing a lot of
patients and sending them out to the
tennessee lab so we basically compared
it
compared our pcr to the tennessee lab
pcr and also we had some reference
material and known concentration that we
could also use
for precision we wanted to see how
reproducible uh the study was
over different days and different um
technologies and we looked at
specifically at the coefficient
values for uh or reproducibility
uh for uh looking at the city values of
the positive control
for sensitivity we were able to get
tighter uh
positive cultures at tighter
concentration and dilute those down and
do our limited detection studies and for
specificity we looked at the performance
of the essay against different types of
candida
and
other types of organisms as well and the
results were really good um and with 100
percent accuracy really good
reproducibility and a limited detection
that we could
prove to be two colony forming units per
reaction
um so we were able to
go live with this test
and introduce it in-house at the
beginning of this year
that was a major win
because it allowed us to for much more
rapid results of course
and um we were able to now introduce the
test uh in the
emr
allow the infection prevention team to
with just a few clicks um identify the
patients put them in isolation and order
both the culture and the pcr we decided
to go live with both tests being done on
the same swab again collecting the
axilla groin one swab and setting up
with the same swap both tests
this allowed for much faster results and
everybody seemed to be very happy that
we were able to do this including the
lab who had been had to delay the
project
for a while
so the volume of testing has increased
over time and
this is showing
real data from when we went live to
pretty much last month
at one point we decided we wanted to
really look at the concordance between
the pcr
and and the culture because we really
were doing a lot of work and a lot of
screening and we wanted to see how much
value the um
the culture was really adding to this
um so we um
compared it and saw that um
for um
the culture we actually had four
patients who are positive by pcr but
negative by culture and in a way this
was sort of expected
and we were able to
confirm that these cases were actually
proven to be true positive based on
their history or subsequent cultures
that were then positive
on the other hand though the culture was
not really identifying any
additional positives there were zero
that were pcr negative and culture
positive so we decided to bring this up
to our collaborators we tend to make
decisions here when it comes to
screening especially in other tests in
the lab really in a collaborative
fashion so we discussed this in our
infectious disease collaborative with
the physicians and as well as infection
prevention and we decided that it was
really time to stop
doing both cultures and pcr and so we
discontinued that in august and are
proceeding just with a pcr test as our
screening test
today we have screened over 1300
patients and i'm sure we will continue
to do so and probably increase the
screening even further
um it is
a daunting task to have one more test
with such high volume
however we feel this is really important
for for the system
uh we also really keep a very close eye
on the turnaround time of the results
because obviously these patients
are in isolation until proven uh
not guilty so to speak and so we really
keep a
really close eye on the data and here
i'm showing the volume of testing in
each month and you can see that it's
going up and down but mostly up
um in some cases there are some events
that prompt more screening and i'm
showing you the turnaround time from the
in-lab
stamp to the final result the verified
results which is important but um also
as important and more important is the
collect to verify turnaround time which
hovers around 30 hours um
at the moment we're batching once a day
and uh we're not doing uh much testing
over the weekend but we're already
thinking that we want to do a little bit
better than that and probably we start
testing heavily on the weekend as well
and keep in mind that we're doing this
in a central lab location uh so there's
some transportation for some of our
samples from coming from our hospitals
we are uh the radius of the daycare
health system is is pretty wide in terms
of mile and transportation so at one
point we may need to
decentralize this test and put it closer
to the patients in the hospital labs
we're not quite ready to do that now but
something definitely that we need to
keep in mind
another important thing
to consider is the fact that we need to
give better tools to our
clinical teams to identify patients so
we cannot just rely on sexual prevention
identifying these patients but we need
to uh
make the emergency department the er
team in charge of identifying these
patients when they first come into the
hospital so now we've introduced
other tools called the power plan where
questions are being asked as at the
triage whether the patients have had a
stay in a long term acute care hospital
or they're coming from a facility that
has known cases of the oris and there's
active doh departmental health
communication on a list of
facilities that have those so if the
questions are answered yes
then the actual the pcr test is actually
ordered automatically so that we don't
miss any potential colonized patients
so having said all of this i want to
conclude um
with a few thoughts uh
i think i've imparted on all of you that
candida ores is a fungus that has very
very serious consequences and is
spreading in the healthcare facilities
and in our in the us as well as the rest
of the world
um accurate identification of this
organism was not always possible in the
past however new methodologies are
available new software so accurate
identification of both infections in the
positive culture as well as colonies
patients is now possible
specifically rapid identification of
colonized patients is really necessary
and needed to prevent hospital-based
transmissions
molecular based methods are really ideal
for screening because there's they're
fast
and they're
very convenient
and uh of course they're it's even
better when they're available in house
and the last thought i have is that
really for all these projects
as we have learned through covet but
also through uh with this specific
project on candida or is that
inter-departmental collaboration is
really vital to make things successful
um really lab cannot work in a silos and
so we work very very closely with
infection prevention infectious disease
specialists and the hospital staff
and on that note um i want to thank my
collaborators at daycare on this project
the lab supervisor who did
really spearheaded all the validation
studies uh the technical director dr
ceferi the technical director of
microbiology the director of infection
prevention suzanne chandler
dr gupta who's the quality and project
improvement director
and of course thank you
also to the dinosauring molecular team
thank you maura for your informative
presentation
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor dinosaur and molecular
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions submitted today and during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye